Harry and Megan are waging a narrative
battle against the palace whether
they're winning depends where you're
reading and in their adopted Californian
Hometown Prince Harry's local Bookshop
is awaiting the arrival of his
autobiography when I knew that it was
coming out I called my Publishers up
right away and said put me on the list
it's one of the books that I would order
by the carton I think a lot of people
were more
interested in how it affected the queen
before she passed on and that sort of
thing it just kind of family Dynamics
more than anything political or anything
like that it's a soap opera and
everybody wants to know what's going to
happen in the next episode
Montecito is an enclave of the super
wealthy where Harry and Megan's 15
million dollar home is considered
mid-range as the TV and book deals Mount
up neighbors are beginning to question
the motive of their media offensive the
story is interesting because it keeps
evolving right and it's it's he said she
said they said they said you know and I
see it makes great television do you
think most people later on that Harry
and Megan's side my observations is most
women is on Megan's side and most men
are on why are they doing this people
here they get 100 million dollar
contract from Netflix they're making
that money is not theirs it's for their
company they have to hire people they
have to do whatever so I'm sure it's
partially
due to a lifestyle that they want and
what can they sell people here were
surprised when Harry and Megan moved to
this estate in Montecito in 2020 they
say it gives them the privacy and the
quiet life that they crave which begs
the question why are they reigniting
this war with the royal family which
will undeniably thrust them back into
the spotlight there is certainly more
sympathy for their plight here than in
the UK Americans look at Prince Harry
and they see a vulnerable young man who
is being emotionally honest for perhaps
the first time in his life whereas the
British tend to see a spoiled rich kid
with every privilege that life can
afford moaning about the Gilded cage he
found himself in whichever side you're
on the more he reveals about the inner
trauma and trials of the institution he
was once part of Prince Harry already on
the other side of the world grows
further from his family Martha Kellner
Sky News Montecito